hi there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
what is your name my name is Tara
Ericsson Tara Ericsson knows a thing or
two about having a lot of rage in her
soul yeah so I thought it'd be good if
we watched a video that was sent over to
us by quite a few people it master for a
long time and I was like you know what
I've Tara here as guest
I don't think Tara has even seen a video
like this before I probably haven't
it's called ultimate gamer rage I'm
assuming it's a compilation of gamers
losing their leadership that just sounds
like a fun old time that sounds like me
every morning when I'm making coffee is
Tara has quite the temper very abusive
and yes hard part is in this climate
people only believe women and if I say
something about no one's gonna believe
me yeah you better believe it but Wow
yeah he's gonna be over there after I
leave crying I'm not even allowed use
the bathroom it smells terrible in here
now he can hold it
ah lady Brady really good act out or I
don't know because why is a camera
rolling
Brothers [ __ ] you people leave so much
money off of a bit of a one of the most
better anything
[Laughter]
I swear these are good act outs cuz why
is a camera rolling I mean they're just
recorded as boys oh my god oh my god oh
my god I mean what are you doing
no step oh my god yes dad stop Jack
tonight I've heard of like or stories of
kids like killing their parents over not
because like like actually killing them
so this is a death really yeah
I have the same Oh God oh my god
very real video this guy
oh my god Beauty my god he's gonna go
from this is to like range it tricky to
run in don't [ __ ] stop my oh my
[ __ ] titty sprinkler no [ __ ] tiny
little pooper oh god I actually broke my
controller oh [ __ ] look the [ __ ] I never
happened before
I always thought he's so stupid when
people arranged
[Laughter]
oh my goodness I'm everything frustrated
but that hope has been my mindfulness
money the same kid from earlier this kid
needs like medical needs to be Medicaid
he's a psycho spoiled it's already
broken
[Music]
Tirion people are insane Oh
[Music]
like a famous twitch guy famous some of
the biggest youtubers of all time you
know nothing Johnson yeah i'ma China one
of the greatest videos I've ever seen
don't tell all those screens
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god it's not the guitar recording
it okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
why is it not giving me dude [ __ ]
I just can't imagine getting this mad at
Eddie a game where I destroy [ __ ] never
oh my god he's about to lose his mind Oh
God
this is not a good norm it's a while
[Music]
it's scarier what you can't even see
them that was scary
I'm sorry I got crumbs on your table
this is what happened feel like I need
to read a note on the air right now
there's the thing called notes from your
therapist so that we're all we feel
better time nuts for us to you lots of
us have patterns in relationships of
avoiding feelings or managing other
people's problems and emotions why
problems and emotions I just randomly
clicked on this they've got problems and
emotions we'd start to make sense when
you think about what you had to do as as
what as a kid did you think about what
you had to do as a kid to feel safe
mm-hmm well clearly these kids had
nothing to do to feel safe control is
what they got
look there's been many times where John
and I are working in here yeah I'm my
girlfriend Olivia who's sending you guys
now she'll be playing God of War in the
other room in the literary and I'll hear
her what happened to TV swearing and
shouting and screaming and it's amusing
but if she ever like burrow
controller or like through at the TV
yeah I'd be like you no more games no
more games no I've been furious at a
game before sure
have I been losing my [ __ ] yeah but I've
never once like thought to throw my
controller on the ground or hit the TV
my mind immediately goes to it's a lot
of money right there that's like a few
hundred a thousand bucks right there
they destroyed cuz you got mad at a
[ __ ] video game really they all might
be bipolar I don't know man it's just a
game that's a stimuli for them
the game is their life that's what
happens when gaming turns into your life
and then the only thing good or winning
in your life is winning the game then
you don't have anything else to be like
happy about that age-old argument that
you've always heard about like that I've
always found to be silly I feel like you
show those people this video if they
feel like they have an argument
yeah like when it gets real is when it's
scared it's terror with that that one
dude broke it and his TV and he's like I
have anger problems
whoa this guy's like owning up right now
to some real [ __ ] because what's scary
about it is what triggers them outside
of the videogames as their person with
other people that's the terrifying part
it's like are they able to control
themselves at all like the one kid who's
with his brothers they have a nice home
right where he's just like this I'm
unplugging [ __ ] I'm walking away no
matter what they're saying is just like
you do his brothers the whole time
thrashing [ __ ] outside I feel like that
kind of kid needs some real vacation go
to juvie for a minute honestly nothing
to me though topped a really early one
with the girlfriend yeah we'll see to me
there are some of these where I'm like
if the camera doesn't move and I don't
hear a voice behind it I know it's
probably set up to get millions of views
on YouTube which is fine I really
believed her I really really did and I
also think that any other boyfriend in
that position would be like no you see
her pick it up and you'd be like dude
I'm gonna take this go in the room and
cool the
maybe because in reading record she is
terrifying but like whose regret the
phone is sitting there and also when she
gets up he kinda has a smirk on it well
that's why I believe it because at first
it's just like funny and weird lívia
there are times I'll be taunting in a
playful way
yeah we're being competitive and
especially if I'm winning and I've
learned not to do that anymore because
it like at first I'm like hahaha look at
her getting upset now I'm like oh way no
she's really mad I cross the line into
competitive nature I feel like that's
what happened here because he's like
laughing at her I know yes at first it's
kind of funny just like I she's all
upset at a [ __ ] video game losing it
you could see him transition from
laughter when she picks up the game
that's when he's like oh never mind
oh I've got that's like $400 right
that's a whole video game system and an
Xbox I know not everything's about money
it's just to think that you could get so
mad to the point of willing to throw a
bat but not much because then you gotta
make the time to go get it you know time
to get a new TV oh it's [ __ ] first to
me no not like that broken [ __ ] before
in the past but never very good I don't
think I've ever done any of this I've
yelled but I don't know what this is
what this is is scary
this kids scary because it's a video
game
this isn't like you're having a
relationship fighting out some real [ __ ]
this is a [ __ ] video game it's crazy
to me also there's little parts of me
when the camera is removed and there's
not someone behind it that I'm like this
is a setup they're acting I feel like
some of them might not be real their
ties work but they're good I believe
some good it's oh I felt real it always
felt real I agree with that statement
right there and to sum it all up even
though we have really talked about how
terrifying and how there's a real like
messed up psychological aspect to this
yes this is easily one of the most
entertaining
halation good drop like get your anger
under control and please don't ever turn
into this kind of person over a video
game at the same time this is one of the
best videos I've ever seen maybe you
can't win we need you guys to be this
irrational Miller for our own
entertainer to subscribe to the real
rejects Tara Eriksen I'm glad you could
be here so yeah you're a RAC cancel and
make sure to check out her YouTube
channel click that notification bell a
picture of the day shout out for a man
named Tyler Hague fun fact about Tyler
great cuddly guy I love that man
he lives in Wisconsin and the ps4 that
is in this household he actually
purchased it for myself as a birthday
present because he knew I really want
plated Red Dead been playing that in a
spider-man ps4 hopping back and forth
perfect game perfect video to show you
at all because this is a gamer video
sweet and Tyler he's always like really
calm and just though was chill but I can
see that he probably has a racial side
and his souls got it in him he's got it
in him he's waiting it pop huh you
waiting to pop Tyler who's are you
waiting on it just do it now do it now
while we're both here okay and make sure
you got the camera on so we can watch it
send it to us send it to me I'll send to
him we'll watch it all together put him
on the channel while we watch him rage
out I've got so many ideas you don't
even know I don't know why but for some
reason my butt cheeks are clenched
shaking
why is my oh boy was it when I went huh
you ready to pop and he just went
oh you got a what do they call it what's
the thing that pops its head out go for
those that like a groundhog a ground say
when you got poop that's waiting to come
out
Oh prairie-dogging yep maybe cuz you're
doing that yeah so many options we are
cutting the camera don't cut any in
there fine